hey guys how's it going I've got some
pretty somber news and I'll get straight
to the point my childhood dog buddy who
you guys have probably seen in pictures
and videos I posted on the channel
passed away yesterday morning and it's
heartbreaking in and of itself you know
it's not quite the same as losing a
family member but to me that dog was
family like we raised that dog since she
was this big I mean the reason her name
is buddy is because when we first got
her we thought that she was a boy and we
only learned later that uh it was she
was not
and so basically already wood had been
calling her buddy so we changed the
buddy with a why to a buddy with an AI
and so when I when I was really growing
up like ever since like from junior high
to like now buddy was the sweetest dog
like the goodest girl to ever exist and
you know I've shed my tears I've talked
to my family but what's even more
heartbreaking about it is like I've been
spam recording for the past two weeks
for this trip that I was going to take
tomorrow I was gonna drive all the way
back to Cincinnati with chica in the car
so that chica and Buddy could meet and
sad to say
like I miss my chance on that one and
that just sucks it sucks for multiple
reasons because number one it wasn't
able to happen even though I know I know
that they would have been best friends I
know that for a fact
they are super sweet Golden's from
opposite ends of the world but I know
that they would have been the best of
friends but what sucks even more is
knowing that I had so many opportunities
to make that happen I've had chica for
just about two years now over two years
now I've had chica and in those two
years from the very first day that I got
her I wanted her to meet buddy and I
didn't make that happen and I know I
can't blame myself and letting eating me
up inside and I don't I'm not letting it
like Spiral me down in depression but it
got me thinking about like opportunities
that just pass you by because you think
it can wait you know I don't have a I
don't have a big sweeping life lesson to
learn about this I don't have a big
sweeping like change I'm like I learned
this lesson so X on the channel it's
gonna change forever and that's a
markiplier promise it's um I'm not
anything about that but what I did learn
was that you know it's very easy to make
excuses to push back the things that are
important but seem like they can wait
you know I I remember so many times that
I would talk to my friends or my family
back in Cincinnati and and be like oh
yeah yeah yeah I'll come back next month
I'll come back next month and then the
month would roll up and I go like oh you
know I got busy this month
I'll make sure next month I promise next
month and it's like and it's super it's
super easy to get caught up in that
cycle and even though you know me I I
did plan to come this month I wanted to
come back for Christmas and I am still
doing it and I prepared for it and I
made videos for it because I managed my
time well and I did everything right but
still was just a little bit too late and
you never know when that opportunity's
gonna come you know you can't beat
yourself up because it happened this one
time and you can't eat yourself up
because oh if only I had done X more you
know it's
it's just important to see the things
that are important right now and to
identify the things that actually can
wait and not push the things that are
most important into the waiting colony
because you never know when they're gone
you never know like it could be tomorrow
it could be a year from now like why
take that risk tell the people who are
important to you that they're important
to you now you know tell the people that
you love that you love them today see
those members of your family including
dogs that left such an impression on you
through your whole life you know see
them more see them with the same
intensity that a dog sees you when
you've come back from a trip because I
said I remember every single time I came
back to my stepmoms house it was a house
that I kind of grew up in maybe you know
the longer I've been away the less it
feels like home but when I come back and
I open that door and bloody was there
just wagging her tail to no end as soon
as she could tell it was me she just
exploded with joy every single time and
and that's what I'm gonna remember you
know that's what I'm gonna and you know
I may not be able to ever see that again
out of buddy but I see that with chica
and I think chica spreads that same joy
in a different way you know you could
never replace it but chica has that joy
and I want to make sure I give her the
most joy she could ever have in her life
because buddy never had a bad day in her
life like that's something my step mom
always says buddy never had a bad day in
her entire life every day was filled
with happiness sunshine and love and you
know I think there's something to be
something to be learned
so anyway I've provided down in the
description a few videos that buddy has
been in from the very first one where I
actually announced a livestream with her
and - a few more that I was just doing
update vlogs from when I was back home
and I don't know just if you guys want
to check them out they're down in the
description below and as like I said I'm
going on Christmas break but that
doesn't mean the videos are gonna stop I
have a bunch of videos recorded and I'm
gonna be recording more today and I'm
gonna be strewn um about all through
Christmas I'm gonna be recording stuff
all on the home I'm going to be making
videos because it's fun to make videos
and I'm gonna be prioritizing time with
my family and then immediately after
that we're going on tours so if you guys
haven't seen yet we are going on tour
again we've got shows they're all listed
in the description below
we're doing the u.s. in January and then
in February we're doing Europe so check
down there for all the shows I don't
know if I'm going to be doing this tour
again after these shows so these might
be the last time we go out just thank
you everybody that has seen it and thank
you everybody that has supported it and
it's gonna be okay
because I I know I'm not perfect and I
don't try to be and you know I don't try
to make these videos as some testament
to how wonderful a human being I am you
know but I learned things from these
things you know these moments in my life
I learned and I try to take the best
parts of it and not let the worst parts
bog me down because you know I'm not
perfect but I try to be a little bit
better every day
and hopefully that's gonna give me some
and if it doesn't know well as long as
they got the right things in mind and
what's really important in my heart you
know I think I make it through it okay
so thank you everybody so much for
watching I've got some last-minute stuff
to record them and be doing the new
Resident Evil DLC today I'm gonna be
finishing up doki-doki literature Club
I've been recording it I haven't been
posting it and then I'm going to drive
for about three days straight back to
Cincinnati so thank you everybody so
much for watching look forward to some
cool stuff coming at you real soon
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye